what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python a panda's tutorial video
as you well know all the cool kids plot
in 3d now so now we need to teach you
guys how to do it so with that let's go
ahead and get started so we have we do
need to have Matt putt lips pipe lot
still but we also have to import NPL
underscore or actually rather from MPL
dot or underscore toolkits dot and plot
3d import axes free capital d now that's
why I don't think it'll work with pandas
if anybody knows how you can plot 3d
with pandas feel free to let me know
pretty sure you're gonna have to do it
this way though we can leave all of this
other data here except all the plotting
basically so we'll just do that
well we can leave puff show there I
suppose now so let's say we want to
compare maybe price to the high minus
low and then see if there's any
correlation between the high minus low
and and price visually okay so don't
know anybody that does this I just want
to show you 3d plotting with the data
set that we're using so we're gonna say
3d equals P Ltd figure empty parms GC a
and then parentheses projection equals
3d and basically what this does
oops put quotes right this is what this
doesn't notifies that hey we're gonna
plot in 3d now the next thing we want to
do is we're going to make a scatter plot
so we're gonna say 3d dot scatter and
first we're going to say D F dot index
and if that index will just be the index
of the date okay so DF index
and actually let's go ahead and we want
to get rid of index column for now we'll
bring it back one of these days but for
now we want to get rid of that so DF
index is not dates I don't think it's
gonna handle the dates very well outlive
3d so DF down in X now that'll just be a
I think I'll probably start at 0 1 2 3 4
there just goes all the way through my
sort of 1 I'm not sure which one it
starts with we'll find out
so dip in X and then we're gonna say DF
will do H - oh and then DF close okay so
those are the three things about X Y and
a Z now for the scatterplot that we're
gonna do and then we're gonna say 3d die
set underscore X label and then make
some point or quotes there we're going
to copy this paste paste X Y Z our X
label is just the index our Y label is H
- L and then finally our Z label is
close and that will should be enough
we'll find out I suppose and so let's go
ahead and save and run that and we sure
enough we get our 3d plot here so here
we have and just hasn't for over the
record I think the back arrow
okay the arrows don't do anything this
pan basically does what all the clicks
dude zoom works is I mean it hits a
figure and I don't know if subplots
works or not I guess we'll find out oh
it does ok so we can do that but
basically the arrows don't work there's
no point to this and zoom works at least
though now so if we do this we can see
okay so this was the price looks like I
think it starts at 0 I don't know
so this is price right and then what we
can do those we can turn this a little
bit right and we can see this is high
minus low so it's the high minus low
goes it almost looks like that up mostly
happens when price is low right because
this was the close price so this seems
to happen more often like the high minus
low variance of volatility eyes
pose we could call it seems to happen
more when the clothes price is lower
than when the clothes price is higher it
seems to get pretty tight as you get
higher price which is odd you would kind
of assume that high minus low is either
at the extremes on either end but looks
more to me like it's kind of low but
anyway so that's just an example doing
some 3d plotting I thought zoom worked
but it does not look like zoom works I
lied anyway so there's your 3d plot we
have a lot of plots on here so it kind
of lags on my computer and depending on
what kind of computer you have it
probably lags even more this is all
plotting with your CPU rather or not
your GPU if you plot it on your GPU
you'd get a lot better results but this
is CP your ear so anyway we close out of
that and so there's always like all
kinds of stuff that we can apply here
week apply something like this like we
can have index high minus low and then
we can do let's say volume here and so
we can compare you know does how old is
the high minus low react with volume
right so we have index that's just so
really we won't notice anything here but
as volume goes up while volume first of
all volume has gone up since the
beginning interesting and then here we
can compare as high minus low gets
larger what is volume do or as volume
gets larger what does high minus low do
so we can see that as the two of them
rise to kind of together because there
you can see like as this goes up it
seems as the volume goes up but there
are some more volume is still kind of
low anyway probably no no no money to be
made in this kind of analysis but just
want to show you guys 3d plotting just
some basic examples now you can do all
kinds of 3d plots you can do planes you
can do bars and all that I have
tutorials on those as well if you want
to dig into more 3d plotting you can
check those out so anyway that's going
to leave this video if you guys have any
questions or comments for pretty leave
them below as always thanks for watching
things for all this for the
subscriptions and until next time